Em julho de 2022, eu fiz um vídeo sobre
as moléculas da longevidade. Eu falei
sobre nada de mais, nicotinamina,
mononicleotídio,
nicotinamida, ribosídio, resveratrol,
ctuínas. E na época a promessa era
tentadora, suplementar precursores de
nadis para reverter o envelhecimento. Eu
expliquei como nada de mais é
fundamental para as mitocôndrias, como
ele ativa as cirtuínas, como seus níveis
caem com a idade. Tudo isso continua a
verdade. O que mudou foi evidência sobre
o que acontece quando você tenta repor
isso artificialmente. E eu preciso ser
honesto com você. A ciência avançou e
algumas coisas que eu disse merec
atualização crítica.
Primeiro, o que que continua válido? O
nad
essencial pro metabolismo energético.
Ele realmente diminui com a idade, as
cirtuínas realmente dependem dele. O
problema não está na bioquímica, o
problema está na tradução clínica. Uma
metaanálise publicada em 2025 na
Criticals Reviewal em Food Science
Nutrition analisou 12 ensaios clínicos
com 503 participantes e o resultado, a
suplementação de NMN, que é a
nicotinamida, mononicleídio, realmente
aumenta os níveis de nadimais no sangue.
Isso é fato. Mas aqui tá o ponto
crucial. A maioria dos desfechos
clinicamente relevantes não foi
significativamente diferente entre o
grupo que tomou NMN e o grupo placebo,
ou seja, o grupo da farinha. Os
pesquisadores concluíram e eu cito, pode
existir um exageros benefícios da
suplementação de NMN no campo. Exagero é
uma palavra forte vindo de uma revisão
sistemática. Mas o golpe mais duro veio
de um lugar inesperado, o Interventions
Testing Program do Nag. Esse é o padrão
ouro para testar substâncias que
prolongam a vida. Eles usam milhares de
camundongos em três centros diferentes
com metodologia rigorosa. Em 2021,
publicaram os resultados para
nicotinamida ribosídio, o famoso NR.
Resultado, nenhum efeito na longevidade.
Nem machos, nem fêmeas, nada zero. E
olha que esse programa já validou outras
substâncias, como a rapabicina. Quando
algo funciona, eles detectam o NR,
infelizmente não funcionou. E tem mais
um estudo publicado em dezembro de 2024,
randomizado, controlado, testou 2000 mg,
ou seja, 2 g de nicotinamida ribosídio
por 24 semanas em pacientes com long
COVID ou COVID longa. O objetivo era ver
se melhoraria a função cognitiva e a
recuperação dos sintomas. O nada de mais
no sangue subiu, os sintomas não
melhoraram, a cognção não melhorou, os
pacientes continuaram exatamente como
antes. Então vamos recapitular. Os
precursores de nadimais aumentam o NAD
mais no sangue, isso está comprovado.
Mas aumentar o nad
se traduzindo como deveria e benefícios
funcionais mensuráveis e humanos. É como
encher o tanque de combustível de um
carro que está com motor quebrado. O
combustível está lá, mas o carro não
anda. E por que isso acontece? Existem
algumas hipóteses. Primeira, o nada mais
no sangue pode não refletir o que está
acontecendo dentro das células,
especialmente nas mitocôndrias. Segunda,
talvez o problema do envelhecimento não
seja a falta de nada mais, mas sim a
capacidade das células de utilizá-lo.
Terceira, os benefícios vistos em
animais podem não se traduzir para
humanos que têm metabolismo e tempo de
vida completamente diferentes. E aqui
entra a visão funcional que eu sempre
defendo. Quando eu fiz aquele vídeo
original, eu disse uma coisa que
continua sendo absolutamente verdadeira.
De nada adianta suplementar se você não
fizer os pilares básicos, alimentação,
atividade física, sono, controle de
estresse. Sabe o que é irônico?
Exercício físico aumenta nada de mais
naturalmente. Jeju intermitente também
aumenta nada de mais naturalmente.
Recisão calórica, adivinha? Aumenta na
demais naturalmente. E essas
intervenções têm décadas de evidência
mostrando benefícios reais. Então, o que
fazer com essa informação? Se você já
está gastando dinheiro com NM ou NR
esperando reverter o envelhecimento, a
evidência atual ainda não sustenta essa
expectativa. Se você tá tomando porque
não faz mal e pode ajudar, ok, tudo bem,
é sua decisão, não tem problema. Mas não
deixe isso substituir o que realmente
funciona. Agora, existe um grupo para
que os precursores de inadimais podem
fazer sentido pessoas com disfunção
metabólica significativa. Uma
metaanálise mostrou que os benefícios
aparecem mais em quem tem doença
cardiovascular ou deslipidemia. Outra
encontrou que pequenas doses de NMN
tiveram impacto na resistência em doses.
Ou seja, não é que a molécula seja
inútil, é que ela não é a panaceia
universal que foi vendida. E sobre as
outras moléculas que eu mencionei
naquele vídeo, a berberina continua com
evidência sólida pro metabolismo.
A quercetina e fizetina como senolíticos
ainda estão sendo estudadas, mas tem
mecanismos interessantes. O resveratrol,
sem nada de mais adequado, continua
tendo problema de biodisponibilidade.
E a metiformina, rapamicina continuam
sendo as únicas substâncias com
evidência robusta de extensão de vida em
modelos animais, mas com ressalvas
importantes que já discuti em outros
vídeos. A lição aqui é simples. A
ciência é um processo, não um destino. O
que parece promissor hoje pode não ser
confirmado amanhã. E quando a evidência
muda, a gente precisa ter humildade de
atualizar o discurso. Eu poderia ter
ignorado esses estudos e continuar
repetindo que NMN é maravilhoso, mas
isso não seria honesto com você e nem
comigo mesmo. Saia do vídeo agora se
você gosta de ficar no superficial. Eu
vou te contar uma verdade conveniente. O
YouTube e o conselho me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, omitir protocolos
controversos sobre nada de mais e
longevidade, por exemplo, eu não posso
falar abertamente sobre as estratégias
que realmente eu uso para otimizar
função mitocondrial, os marcadores que
eu monitoro ou os compostos que
considero mais promissores que NMN. Na
comunidade fechada não tem esse filtro.
Eu compartilho os exatos protocolos que
eu uso na minha clínica, incluindo minha
abordagem atual para saúde mitocondrial,
que vai muito além de simplesmente tomar
um suplemento, os cofatores essenciais,
o time e por algumas pessoas respondem,
outras não. É basicamente ter acesso ao
meu cérebro médico sem intermediários.
Live semanais respondendo perguntas, PDF
com 47 protocolos exclusivos, grupo no
WhatsApp com pessoas maravilhosas. Se
você quer a visão funcional real, sem
simplificação para as massas, clique em
seja membro. E não é para curiosos, é
para quem quer resultados. Agora, se
você quer ir ainda mais fundo, tem o
nível dois. A cada duas semanas, fazemos
live de imersão total com 2 horas de
duração, desse secando artigos
científicos linha por linha, como esse
estudo sobre nada mais e longevidade que
a maioria dos médicos ainda não conhece,
debatendo controvérsia que ninguém ous
tocar. E tem mais, seu nome será
mencionados nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna a parte
visível dessa comunidade elite que está
reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria assiste passivamente,
você estará ao meu lado construindo
conhecimento de verdade. E poucos têm
essa coragem. Será que você tem? E já
que estamos falando de mitocôndrias e
energia celular, você precisa entender
como cozima Q10 e PQQ funcionam de
verdade e porque eles podem ser mais
interessantes que NMN para muitas
pessoas. Assista esse vídeo aqui sobre
os seis suplementos essenciais para
idosos que vai complementar
perfeitamente o que você aprendeu hoje.
Agradecimentos especiais aos nossos
membros queridos dos estudos avançados
na comunidade fechada do YouTube.
Começando pelos novos membros que
entraram recentemente, Coruja Curiosa,
Walter Salgado, Luciano Silva Porinelli,
Luciano Elias, Carlos Roveri, Odonor
Pinheiro, Cíntia de Assis Oliveira,
Jorge Cabral e Fernando Machado. Sejam
muito, muito bem-vindos. Agradeço também
aos membros que fizeram upgrade pros
estudos avançados. Coruja curiosa, Irma
LC, Iana Medicina,
Adriane BMS, Dr. Ana Paulo Rodrigues,
José Fortunato Murtinho, Sou Jucioli,
Cristina Carol, Romana Morari, Estela
Mares Silva, Elô Terapias Integrativas e
Luís Anselmo Neves. Obrigado pela
confiança e elevar o nível de
participação. Um abraço especial aos
membros que retornaram à comunidade,
Alex Caldas, Marcelo Pimentel e Cláudio
Leitão. Que bom ter vocês de volta. Eu
quero fazer um reconhecimento especial
aos membros mais fiéis. Estela Mares com
57 meses de fidelidade, Dra. Ana Paula
com 45 meses, Marcelo Pimentel com 23 e
Elô Terapia Integrativas com 9 meses de
história conosco. A todos vocês eu
agradeço de coração pelo apoio
prestrado. Vocês fazem diferença nessa
comunidade.